clark county commissioners want to take
a deeper look at how businesses that
host
larger events are doing with the virus
so they plan to look at results of a
survey that was supposed to be done by
business owners
joe muller giving us a look at how the
county will use those results he's live
at decatur and desert in with more
tonight joe
from major concerts to stores like the
grocery store behind us here county
commissioners want to take a look at
businesses where a lot of people gather
to see if they're doing their part
in the fight against coven 19. some
people who have events planned over the
next few months
are going to be keeping a close eye on
what the county does do
it is an awards ceremony where we take
time each year to recognize women
sonya pedowitch is the president of the
national association of women and
business owners
their big event is planned for this fall
i think like everyone else is the
the consistent curveballs with covid
it's constantly changing
and not knowing you know which way to go
making sure that people feel comfortable
as kobe 19 cases rise and clark county
looks at more mandates she is anxious to
see if any changes will have to happen
for her event
it's on our mind right we want to be
able to gather again
last week commissioners passed a mandate
to require employees to wear masks in
public places
also part of that mandate was this
survey it was designed for businesses
that
host more than 250 people like grocery
stores or hotels
businesses are supposed to report to us
they're confidential but
they're basically to to tell us how they
going forward hope to make sure that
that their businesses are not spreading
the virus
county commissioner tick sigerblum says
it asks about testing and vaccine
information and even ideas from business
owners
background information we can use to
figure out if we need to go forward and
if we do go forward
what what ideas we could use he says
they want to get a handle on the virus
to avoid another shutdown
what we don't want to do is to
drastically make any changes
that first are not going to make a
difference and second can be enacted
but the flip side is we want to make
sure that that we don't
push our economy backwards pedowitch
says it's hard to think of more mandates
but understands commissioners are doing
what they need to
i appreciate the way that they're
looking at it and i hope that they're
taking all things into consideration
now back out here live these surveys
were due today they'll be looking at the
results of these coming up at the next
meeting which is set for august 17th but
sigelum says they will take a look
sooner
if needed reporting live joe muller 8
news now